barclays trotz und richtig richtig viel
erfahrungen also ich denke hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
hier auf einem kanal und zwar beim
weihnachtsgeschenk an euch und zwar 20
acts in minecraft das wäre eigentlich
material was ich jetzt vorstelle für
sieben wochen also für zwei monate
minecraft folgen allerdings soll das so
mehr oder weniger bei den
weihnachtsgeschenken euch sein und ihr
hört schon direkt an meiner stimme meine
stimme ist komplett im eimer ich bin
total krank ist tut mir leid dass ich
das ganze jetzt ein bisschen schneller
mache allerdings möchte ich einfach
nicht meine stimme weiter belasten
ich würde einfach ein like als gute
besserung nehmen von euch damit die
ganzen kommentare folge ist beim wert
und auch einfach gebt bitte eine
bewertung ab egal ob daumen hoch oder
daumen runter ob ich so etwas gefällt
als weihnachtsgeschenk und einfach frohe
weihnachten und jetzt viel spaß beim
video der erste effekt hat etwas mit dem
tag heute an sich zu tun und zwar am 24
dezember kann man wenn man hier ins
inventar geht im creative mode und man
sich ja eine kiste dann ist diese kiste
in einem christmas design das ist bei
ich weiß nicht ob es bei welchen anderen
teams auch noch der fall ist
allerdings ist es halt so dass es
grundsätzlich in minecraft drin ist als
ihr braucht euch deswegen nichts runter
laden alle kisten sind in diesem
christmas format hier enthalten immer an
weihnachten das wird irgendwie mit
sondern datei die irgendwie auch dabei
aktiviert deswegen immer am 24 dezember
ist überall auf der welt diese kiste
eine weihnachts kiste der zweite effekt
es mehr oder weniger ein tipp den ich
euch gehen möchte und zwar kennen das
mit sicherheit schon sehr viele leute
genauso über allen facts jeder fällt
wird irgendwem irgendwie schon mal
bekannt vorkommen bzw
diesen effekt kennen deswegen ist für
alle leute erstmal wieder gedacht
werbeblatt typisches szenario typischer
disclaimer hier wieder dass keine fakes
ruhig sagt dass keiner die kennt sondern
das ist einfach so sexy eventuell einige
noch nicht wissen und zwar wenn ich hier
auf einen block bauen möchte kann ich
einfach shift gedrückt halten
das geht halt mit allen möglichen
blöcken also ich kann ja alles mögliche
draufsetzen und wenn ich halt nicht
schiff gedrückt halte bin ich halt in
den mini drin das wussten vielleicht
einige nicht wenn ich zum beispiel hier
irgendwie eine wand bauen möchte und die
geht hier dann so lange dann kann ich
hier entweder einfach so machen oder ich
bin einfach direkt darüber und halte
dabei schiff gedrückt dann kann ich das
wunderschöne in eine wand reinbauen für
den dritten weg muss ich ganz glücklich
aus meiner kleinen arena rausgehen und
zwar kann
kakteen unter wasser bauen und das als
einzige von diesen decoration blogs und
zwar könnte die ganz einfach hier
ausbauen
und wenn ich halt und ein kaputt mache
zerfällt zeit allerdings geht es mit
keinen anderen sachen das zerfällt halt
wirklich alles um wasser das geht nur
mit kakteen der vierte effekt ist ein
kleiner tipp zu den command blogs und
zwar muss man eigentlich bei dem command
jsoc wenn man einen blog zum beispiel
setzen will wenn ich jetzt einsetzen
will muss ich erst also diesen befehl
gegen / set blogs koordinate yz
koordinate dann die blockade und
eigentlich noch die blockpartei replays
allerdings geht es auch so und zwar habe
ich das so als mal gebaut und jetzt
kommt hier ein tnt und ja da ist ein
kleiner trick bleibt ganz gewissen
abzukürzen muss man halt nicht mehr die
block datum replace him schreiben oder
nächste fake besagt dass wenn ich hier
ein rosenblatt dingsbums teil hinsetzte
darüber diese teile hier machen im
moment
und jetzt muss ich das hier weg schlagen
und danach wieder dahin setzen hatte
okay das ist natürlich klar takt aber
egal bei mir klappt es nicht ich habs
jetzt kann es oft probiert
ich habe einfach ein tolles timing und
zwar kriegt man es dann hin dass dieses
seerosen blatt auf dem sand drauf ist
damit ihr seht dass es funktioniert und
wie es funktioniert habe ich euch jetzt
mal ihm ein video von fred zoki
eingeblendet der euch das jetzt mal gut
erklärt oder wie zahlen machen wir
danach direkt mit dem nächsten
den text effekt besagt dass wenn ich
ganz ganz ganz ganz weit nach oben
fliegt und mich gleich einfach
runterfallen lassen und dann einfach
kurz vorm boden game online gebe das
denn keinen fall schaden bekommen also
komplett ran so ich habe ziemlich keinen
fall schaden bekomme ich kann das ganze
noch mal machen damit ihr seht das
funktioniert prima bla also ich hab gern
einfach kopiert ins clipboard und jetzt
wenn ich hier eben hoch fliegen
so und jetzt im flug das eingeben zackig
kriegt vielleicht ein bisschen fall
schauen ob ich kriege ein erster plan
fall schaden durch den game mode 0 weg
wache der nächste facts auch sehr gern
und ich könnte wetten dass unter 1
prozent diesem feld kennen und zwar
denkt man eigentlich mit schneebällen
kann man keinen schaden machen
allerdings gegen lohn
ich wäre jetzt einfach mal richtig viele
schneebälle rhein sind schneebälle sowas
von wirkungsvoll das ist richtig richtig
geil die sterben alle das ist richtig
richtig gut für irgendwelche sportler
und jetzt sieht das hier so verbrannt um
egal ob auch meine entnehme ich hab' ich
möchte einfach irgendwie so also gegen
lohn sind echt schneebälle sowas von
wirkungsvoll ich kann einfach ein paar
teile drauf schmeißen davon wenn wir ein
stack keine ahnung und dann hat man hier
direkt paar place trotzdem richtig
richtig viel erfahrung dieser effekte
für die tierfreunde ganz besonders cool
und zwar kann ich er normalerweise ist
dieses halsband hier an diesem roth
allerdings wenn ich jetzt mit blau und
mit einem pink darauf ihr kann ich
dieses halsband färben das geht mit
allen möglichen sachen das geht doch
hier mit mit gelb mit grün und damit
kann man eigentlich ganz gut entscheiden
wenn man zum beispiel 200 wer weiblich
ist wenn wir dann vielleicht eher dass
pinkl und wenn möglich ist dann
vielleicht ein blaues oder ein rotes
oder grünes oder ein gelbes halt alle
anderen farben aus abhängig acht effekt
hat auch wieder etwas betonten zu tun
und zwar kann ich jetzt einmal zwei
hunde erschaffen und der eine gott jetzt
mehr so der ein dass jetzt gezählt der
gezähmte und wenn ich den töte so 23
brauche ich drei schläge für dem und bei
einem normalen hund kann ich das einfach
innerhalb von einem schlag ihn töten
ich weiß nicht ob die stärker werden
wenn ihr mit denen so irgendwie zusammen
sei mehr oder weniger wenn ihr euch
gehören aber anscheinend ja schon dieser
fake hat auch wieder etwas mit hunden zu
tun und zwar nicht etwas total war alles
eigentlich und zwar reden wir die ganze
zeit von hunden aber sind eigentlich
wölfe noch 100 ge und zwar ich denke das
wissen auch nur sehr sehr wenige von
euch und zwei wissen dass diese leine
hinzugefügt wurde als die pferde auch
hinzugefügt wurden allerdings kann ich
auch wenn ich jetzt hunde haben oder so
kann ich auch diese hunde an die leine
nehmen und diese hunde mit mir rum
herziehen und hier so ein bisschen durch
die gegend schleudert allerdings wenn
ich dann halt wieder auf den boden wir
bekommen da dieser hund auch fall
schaden und stirbt er wieder hat das
irgendwas mit hunden zu schönen und zwar
geht es um leinen und zwar kann ich ja
ein hund ganz locker ihr sie an der
leine nehmen
mit ihm bisschen rumfliegen etc das gilt
allerdings nicht wenn er in sitz macht
also wenn ihr sitzt macht ist der
einfach so ich kann hier mal eben so
machen so zac dann kann ich dir locker
wie sie mit dem rumpf liegen da weil die
gerade unter kriegt auch fall schaden
aller war da die gerade alle im gesetz
machen geht das nicht also werden die
sitz machen sind die echt quasi sowie
magnetisiert mit dem erdboden und
nochmal hunde ich kann die folge
eigentlich schon rund folgenden aber wir
sind so viele sachen mit nun gerade
einfach so aufgefallen und zwar wenn ich
die hunde jetzt alle so hier nehme also
wenn ich in den sitz jetzt hier weg
mache
wir sind ja quasi nicht mehr
magnetisiert mit dem boden die punkt
punkt ich kann mawson fliegen machen
mühe aber zu viele hunde und wenn ich
jetzt halt diese ganzen runde nehmen
oder auf dem boden klatsche habe ich
keine hunde mehr eu keine hund facts
mehr
nein also ich habe hier einen scharf
dass ein schwachen das halt luca und das
ist hier eingesperrt in einem kleinen
käfig und ich sehe das halt hier ganz
viel ich also wenn ich gegen gegen so
ein blog gucken natürlich nicht aber
wenn ich das so angucke sehe ich das
natürlich
wenn ich allerdings durch glas durch
cook und ich wie sie das schwein hier
quasi trotz man sehe ich jetzt nicht das
ist egal ob es pink ist blau normales
glas hier das geht einfach nicht wenn
ich von hier gucke geht es und ich von
den schweizern visier allerdings
hierdurch nicht also durch glas kann ich
nicht sehen was das für einen namen hat
dieses bestimmte mob dingsbums so
freunde dieser effekt hat etwas mit tnt
zu tun um ein gerät seine welt in die
luft sprengen ein quatsch deswegen ist
es ein kleines türmchen gebaut aber das
ganze kein schaden macht und zwar wenn
ich einen pfeil auf gezündete steen t
she zu kommen dieser fällt zurück ich
laufen ganz gut rüber
ihr seht der comdirect comdirect er
kommt zurück und jetzt explodiert das
tnt und es ist trotzdem nichts kaputt
gegangen
fekter jetzt kommt ist ein bisschen
scary und zwar hab ich das ja schon mal
gezeigt mit einer spinne wohnten wobei
der mann dann halt nur die augen sieht
wenn man da irgendwie tränke darauf
wirft wenn ich ein schaf sporne und es
ganz normal ist und ich werde einen berg
waren der unsichtbarkeit drauf
verschwinden
eine und augen und sieht quasi nur noch
so wolle ihr seht nur noch die rolle von
diesem schaffen das ist richtig richtig
scary dieser effekt ist sehr simpel o2
will ich eine feuerkugel in der hand
haltend dem boden mache dann brennt der
boden allerdings lasse ich das mal
lieber siehe pre intro szene so freunde
dieser fake besagt dass wenn ich mit
einer spitzhacke gras abbaue dass ich
dann durchschnittlich mehr sieht
bekommen als wenn ich das so mit der
hand ab doch jetzt wenn ich hab das
jetzt mal mit der hand abgebaut habe ich
jetzt einzieht bekommen mein ziel war
ich meistens mal ganz kurz welche dann
zieht nach halt einfach ein ab jetzt mit
der spitzhacke dass die ganze abbau habe
ich jetzt schon 1 23 sieht also 4 - 13
also ich habe jetzt dreimal so viele
sitz bekommen wenn ich mit gel wenn ich
die kacke mit einer spitzhacke als wenn
ich das mit diesem links abbauen
außerdem geht die eisen spitzhacke dabei
auch gar nicht kaputt hierbei geht sie
allerdings kaputt
man baut ein kürbis am stellt mit einer
axt ab und eine melone stellt mit einem
schwert dafür gehe ich jetzt mal ganz
kurzen games 0 und zeigt euch jetzt mal
ganz kurz wie schnell das mit der hand
geht dann geht das nämlich so schnell
welches mit einem schwert abbau geht das
so stellen also ein bisschen schneller
und hier sieht man es besonders wenn ich
das miteinander umgeht das so schnell
und hier geht das halt sehr sehr schnell
also mit axt und schwert kann man melone
und kürbis schneller abbauen so freunde
kommen zum fun fact uns war dieser fun
fact diesmal kein fake wirklich in
minecraft sondern einfach so ein fact
über mich und zwar habe ich noch nie
einen fake zweimal vorgestellte glaube
ich zumindest
also es sind mittlerweile über 10 14 15
folgen glaube ich minecraft facts und es
waren in jeder folge jetzt immer drei
vier sechs und ich habe noch nie einen
doppelt vorgestellt also danke an euch
dass mir da echt immer wieder neue geile
sachen zugesendet werden
und ja meine lieben freunde das waren
jetzt 20 fakes beziehen wir eigentlich 9
cent fällt euch jetzt vorgestellt habe
ich hoffe es war doch witzig und
lehrreich für euch so ein bisschen
obwohl ich hier mit meiner stimme ein
bisschen echt am ende bin ich nehme
einfach mal ein like als gute besserung
damit ich die ganzen kommentare volkes
beim werden die könnte auch in die
kommentare schreiben wir euch da so was
jetzt gefallen hat ein zweites geschenk
wünscht einfach allen leuten in den
kommentaren vor weihnachten
wunderschönes fest fakt ist auch dass
ihr gerade dieses video schaut und nicht
bei eurer familie seit also geht jetzt
bitte zu eurer familie und feiert das
schon weihnachten
und sonst würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
das video bewerten würde oder irgendwas
in die kommentare schreiben würde top
ich sowas gefallen hat weil das war es
eigentlich material für 76 folgen also
locker zwei monate deswegen ich habe das
alles jetzt mal ein video gepackt ich
wünsche euch einfach vor weihnachten das
war mein weihnachtsgeschenk an euch und
sonst macht euch eine schöne zeit